[Music]
what's the deal with airplane peanuts
we didn't talk about uh how they're
taking away your scoop scoops ladies
and they're [ __ ] up they trying to
take away your scoop scoops
it's unbelievable i just want to let you
all know right now ladies uh i am with
you i think is your body your choice i
agree with you on that
i agree with you when you say that men
should have no say in the decisions you
make with your bodies those are your
decisions to make and yours alone and i
feel that way because at the end of the
day when we all go up to heaven and
god's like why are we all killing babies
we're going to be like y'all
[Applause]
i think they're very clear whose
decision this was god
looks like you need to pay for your sins
babe
even though i paid for your sins
[Applause]
come on y'all chivalry ain't dead to
that babies you know the rules today is
tuesday july 5th and andrew schultz is
putting on the first ever pay-per-view
live comedy event his special infamous
is dropping on his website for 15 bucks
a ticket july 17th you can buy tickets
right now pre-sale and it's the first
ever pay-per-view like a fight but it's
a comedy special welcome back to the
joke world comedy news update every
single week bringing you the news that
you need to know in the comedy world
whether it be news specials new events
that your favorite comedians are a part
of or even who went on each other's
shows last week so you don't miss any
podcast that you'd like to listen to
normally we do these every single monday
but yesterday was the 4th of july i was
pretty banged up celebrating our
independence so this week it's on
tuesday but every other week will be a
monday comedy news subscribe now so you
don't miss a thing july 17th is when the
special's airing it's 15 bucks per
person and it's streaming off of his
website now a few cool things that are
included with this 15 bucks one you get
access to the special forever so it's
not just when it's streaming you buy it
you get to watch it whenever you want
another key feature is that they're
doing a live podcast after the special
airs so you'll watch a special with
everyone else they want you to be live
tweeting about it you know like like a
fight like a real pay-per-view event it
seems awesome in theory and then there's
going to be a live podcast after with
all the dudes from flagrant schultz and
them talking about the special maybe
fielding some questions so that's
another really cool feature of this if
you're wondering why they're doing this
in the first place there is a little bit
of a backstory to this so schultz was on
the infamous tour running this hour and
they sold it apparently to a streamer a
third party like netflix or comedy
central or hbo somewhere to host the
special like normal comedians do
and basically they're saying when they
sold it to this streamer they keep using
the word streamer i'm gonna just start
calling it netflix because i think we
can all agree schultz wasn't putting his
special on amazon prime or comedy
central even less they haven't ever said
netflix but
we can all agree that it's netflix and i
don't want to keep saying the word
streamer because that makes me think
it's like a twitch stream or bought
their special or something so let's just
call it netflix but it technically might
not be
so they sold it to netflix and they
basically had some notes for them cut
out a few jokes cut out a few lines and
schultz was basically saying on flagrant
today he was like you know these jokes
mean so much to him and to the whole
crew that's worked on them for this last
year and that it just doesn't really
make sense for you know these jokes that
are working on tour that people are
appreciating for these suits at these
companies to be able to pull jokes
people who have never been on stage to
pull jokes who are getting offended on
behalf of other people to be pulling
this art that he's worked so hard on it
just didn't sit right with him so
basically they bought it back from
netflix so they they sold it and then
they bought it back and now they're just
trying to break even on this live stream
sell tickets do a pay-per-view event so
that their jokes can live on and that
they don't have to cut anything i built
my career in the beginning i started it
by doing comedy that they would never
allow on these companies right or these
networks comedy central would never
[ __ ] allow it to be on there
and
it was very successful and i assume it
was very successful because people are
like oh [ __ ] this is the real yeah this
guy's being authentic this guy's being
real he's being truly funny this is kind
of how i like to bust balls with my
friends these are the ideas i like to
see made fun of
and
for me to sacrifice that when i finally
got to this point where we put all this
work into making this [ __ ] special
and something we're all i believe very
proud of i can't speak for you guys but
i think that we're all very proud of
this [ __ ] piece
and to be at that point and then go i'm
just going to water it down so it can be
acceptable it's like why we work so hard
[ __ ] that why we [ __ ] put all this
work in what's the point of that yeah
why we sacrifice so much why we away
every [ __ ] weekend to just put
something out there we're like oh well
it would have been nicer if i was able
to say this or this joke would have been
funnier if i was able to say that from a
fan perspective it's dope that he's
doing something like this because it
shows he cares about us hearing his
jokes and his material as they were
intended to be told more than he cares
about being on netflix and making more
money maybe you know he's willing to buy
this back with his own money to preserve
the art however it's just kind of like
couldn't you see this coming you know
like when you sold this to netflix in
the first place you didn't think that
they were going to have any notes on it
like this is someone in the industry
who's been outspoken against censorship
and about doing things on your own in
their own way it seems like they could
have almost skipped a step and just done
this from the beginning but either way
pretty cool to see a live stream
pay-per-view comedy event and if you're
like it's kind of stupid that you have
to pay 15 bucks to see a special instead
of just you know going on netflix or
whatever and it's it's free or whatever
your monthly subscription is that is
true
but i feel like it's worth 15
to have a no filtered special to have no
censorship in your special and to hear
every joke as it's intended to be told
to me that is worth the 15
i would pay 15 bucks to have a
non-watered-down version of andrew
schultz's comedy rather than going on
netflix and seeing the version that he's
holding back in and that's all edited up
and that's not the tour version to me
this seems worth it i guess what i'm
trying to say is like to just lop that
off or change it
it it's that that that would be very
difficult
yeah you know very very [ __ ]
difficult so
i want to um
maintain the integrity of the piece and
that took you know us
buying it buying it back
basically long story short took us
buying it back and then
and now we're delivering it right to you
guys
and i think the cool thing about this is
that if this works and again this is a
gamble who knows what works you guys
decide if it [ __ ] works if you guys
support it [ __ ] army i hope you guys
do but if it works
and comics find out that they can make
more money doing this than doing
traditional network specials
never be a note again on comedy louis ck
and joe list have a movie coming out
called 4th of july pretty exciting
here's a description of it louis ck
co-wrote 4th of july with comedian joe
list who stars in the film is jeff are
covering alcoholic and jazz pianist who
confronts his family during their annual
independence day vacation louie also has
a small role as jeff's therapist
so pretty cool to see something that
louis ck and joelist wrote themselves
joe is acting in it louie has a small
part if you're a fan of their comedy i
recommend checking this one out i know
that they're doing a few tours talking
about it in new york boston and chicago
and then it's in a few different
theaters and definitely available online
obviously both these guys are great
comedians but this movie just from
watching the trailers and doing a little
bit of research on it seems more of like
a serious film than a comedy movie so i
wouldn't necessarily expect you know
just because these two are great
comedians that this is gonna be like the
funniest movie ever i don't think it's
going to be super bad i think it's going
to be a serious well put together movie
i'm going to check it out i just haven't
yet so 4th of july starring joe list
written by joe and louis ck if you're
going to a wedding yeah not joe because
he's a very close friend but you're
going to a wedding didn't come to my
wedding
was he invited of course
ouch yep
took me to paul mccartney i made up for
it oh yeah okay [ __ ]
oh
god it was on record directed at a movie
it wasn't like you were like i can't
come to the wedding but five years from
now i'll direct a film
he might have known that he's a very
smart guy i got an idiot that's all
right what can you do next wedding i
don't remember why i didn't go i should
have gone yeah or he remembers
yeah i don't know
yeah will you do this if you're at a
restaurant will you walk up to the pool
what was the question
jesus christ i forgot
how do we go to a wedding what are you
giving not to not somebody super close
to i don't want to hear this
i'll give you that i don't want to hear
this answer
really quick just want to give a huge
shout out to everyone who made it
possible for joke world reaching a
hundred thousand subscribers yesterday
i couldn't be more happy about it and
thankful and grateful and uh it's
awesome don't want to spend too much
time talking about it because i think we
still have a long way to go we're gonna
keep going but just shout out to all you
guys who like and comment and subscribe
on these videos and who just love comedy
you know as much as we all do this has
been a great community to be a part of a
bunch of like-minded people with the
same senses of humors fans of the same
comedians who just want to laugh and
enjoy their life so thank you guys so
much 100 000 people got here early we're
going to a million we're going to 5
million 10 million a lot of work to
still do but just want to say thanks the
guest list is where we go through the
podcast of last week to see who went on
each other's shows to make sure that you
don't miss any episodes that you would
want to tune into so starting off with
this past weekend theavon had on mike
perry tiger belly head on fajim anwar
your mom's house did not have a guest
but two bears one cave was sal volcano
and bert christler last week no tom
whiskey ginger had on andy richter from
conan kill tony had on william
montgomery's parents and then joe rogan
last week had on dunkin trestle they
dressed up as fourth of july like
colonial people and that was just a
great episode it's always fun when rogan
and duncan get the costumes out it makes
for a great episode as far as new
specials go obviously andrew schultz and
infamous drops on july 17th we already
kind of covered that one and then stand
up on the spot with jeremiah watkins is
coming out july 11th and he's featuring
mark norman r shafir giannis pappas and
the whole are you garbage gang on that
show which is a really fun show i got to
go to once in austin they do it all the
time but basically people yelling out
topics from the crowd and then these
great comedians just riff on that topic
so it's an awesome show to watch that's
coming out july 11th and then schultz
will be on the 17th that's it for the
joke world comedy news update this week
again today was tuesday but it's usually
on mondays
comment any other podcasts or comedians
or shows that you would like covered in
this comedy update we can easily make
that happen for you want to make sure
that we're covering all the comedy news
that you guys really care about
subscribe to joke world download this
episode on spotify and download all the
joke world podcast episodes if you want
to support the channel and i'll see you
again next time
[Music]
you